Gran Turismo takes the term based on a
true story to a whole other level the
true story of race car driver John
martinborough is brought to life with
exotic cars traveling at 200 miles per
hour on camera experimental angles that
bring the audience into the shot and Jan
himself behind the wheel the raw gnarly
shots of racing captured in this film
have never been done in the history of
Cinema let's get into it something
ultimately unique about this movie is
that the Stunt Driver for the actor is
the real person that is being played yes
Beyond martinborough does the bulk of
stunt driving for Archie medequi and he
couldn't be happier about it Archie is
not a fan of being inside the tiny
cockpit of the race car I have nothing
but respect for young being in the court
is the most difficult thing I have ever
done this might be the first film ever
that the person being depicted is also
the person doing the stunt work
obviously Jan martinborough is an
impressive guy but he never thought
there would be a movie made about his
life when he walked onto set he said it
was one of the most surreal experiences
he's ever had and this is coming from
some who went from zero Driving
Experience well aside from the many
hours of racing video games two you
being behind the wheel at a 140 miles
per hour with just eight months of
training speaking of 140 miles per hour
one of the biggest challenges the
production team faced when shooting this
film was finding the technology that was
able to capture all the cars traveling
at those high speeds we're talking 200
miles per hour most of the time the
director Neil blomkamp wanted everything
to look and feel as physically real as
possible they ended up using this camera
called Rialto which is a detachable
front end of the Sony Venice and it
makes it a very small unit so we can put
it in Tiny Places which is ideal for
cars the team behind this film couldn't
speak more highly of Rialto because
without it they would have had to build
an entire race car from the ground up
with a different camera as the
centerpiece it also gave them the
freedom they wanted to be intentional
about when the shot was inside the car
versus outside so not only did they take
a completely Fresh Approach to capturing
vehicle speed on camera but they did
some experimental Photography in order
to make the audience feel like they were
really there they wanted the viewer to
feel like they were moving with the car
they wanted the movie to feel like a
visceral experience for the viewer the
idea behind this was to create something
fresh they didn't want to recreate
something that had already been done in
another film about racing now part of
that included eliminating every element
that wasn't covering speed that was the
focal point of every captured frame they
also wanted the camera super low to the
ground most of the time with lots of
tarmac which in racer terms is like the
runway the car is zooming down we were
really able to race in a way that's
never been done on film before around
the world I mean that literally they
truly do go to several of the most
famous race tracks from all over the
planet I'm talking Austria Budapest
Slovakia and Dubai we have exotic cars
from Lamborghinis to McLarens all the
way to lmp's Le Mans prototypes and not
only did they have the most exotic cars
in exist distance racing on the most
famous tracks in the world these cars
were really traveling at insane speeds
just inches away from one another so we
know Rialto was used inside the car but
to capture those insane speeds on the
track they used unstabilized cameras
that were attached to the outside of the
car we're not using fully stabilized
it's very raw very known especially the
nice stuff in the rain now for those of
you who aren't familiar with everything
that goes into being a race car driver
myself included you might be surprised
to find out how much goes into the
athletic training aspect of it Archie
was really going through it when he
started his training dude was literally
throwing up on a daily basis because he
didn't want to cheat us out of any of
the car shots every shot of him inside
the cockpit is 100 real he's actually
driving cars at 140 miles an hour
there's a reason these guys are some of
the best athletes in the world because
it is one of the most taxing things he
said nothing could ever prepare you for
that kind of intensity unless you're
just built that way we learned pretty
quickly that I'm not and I am I am an
actor there was also an issue with his
height we've established that the inside
of those cars are incredibly tight
having the actors like Archie inside the
uh torture chamber known as the car it
was such a small space that Archie
couldn't even really fit inside it when
Jan would stunt drive for him they had
to remove the actual seat of the car
when he was done so Archie could get
back in it Orchard chamber indeed
something everyone describes as a
beautiful accident was actually yawn's
role in the film he was originally only
brought on to do one scene obviously we
know he's an incredible driver but the
entire production crew was shocked with
how great he was hitting marks and
driving in a way that was oriented
towards the production after essentially
blowing everyone's Minds he ended up
staying on for the rest of the shoot and
was also utilized as this incredible
pool of information for everyone
particularly when it came to improv so
if you know if there was something very
specific about Jan's life that I needed
to improvise around he was there the
entire time with the near impossible
intimate shots from inside the cockpit
the high speed intensity capture at
Angles almost too close for comfort and
real athletic training that turned your
average actor into a professional race
car driver give or to take a bit of
daily vomiting this movie truly went out
of its way to blow your mind what's your
favorite moment from Beyond
martinborough's true story